Okay. Hi everyone. What I'm going to
talk about today is overlapping
imbalances when they occur in the market
and how you can use them to your
advantage. My name is Michael Btos. I'm
the founder and trader of
orderflows.com. First, a brief
disclaimer. This presentation is for
educational andformational purposes only
and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Futures trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor. An investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading. Past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results. Okay. So what I'm going to talk
about today is stacked imbalances and
how you can profit from them. We all
know what stacked imbalances are. And
when you're talking about imbalances in
the
market, you know, you're talking about
buying or selling imbalances. This is an
orderflows trader chart.
Okay. Yes, I sell an order flows trader
chart. I'm making this video. You know,
someone had commented to me,
well, you can only use it with the order
flows trader chart. Well, yeah, of
course. I mean, that's what the software
is there to do. You know, it's there to
help you find these these things. Um
it's kind of a strange comment but
nonetheless you know here we are you
know these are buying imbalances you
know these blue numbers you know these
red numbers are selling imbalances and
most order flows trader most orderflow
trading software has imbalance feature
in there.
So, you know, my my
software also has a couple extra
features with it. But, you know, for the
main point of this, you know, what I
want to talk about is when you have
overlapping imbalances. Now, here
market's trading trading, boom, you get
a stack buying imbalance. One, two,
three, a stack buying imbalance and
you're thinking, hey, you know, this is
my chance. You know, I should go long,
right? you're going to be looking to get
long, you know, just after here because
you're going to look at this to be a
support level. Okay, then what what
happens? It doesn't work. It fails. You
know, there's no support. These buyers
that were here earlier, you know, where
are they? They've gone. They they bought
what they needed to do and they're not
buying anymore. You know, where's the
buyers? They're gone and the market
sells off. Then you get a selling
imbalance. Now when I say
overlapping what I mean is okay the
order flows trader chart you know just
real quick you know why I talk about uh
you know my my software having a little
bit extra extra features is where is it
here say
you're looking uh where is it here you
know the imbalance box size is five 1 2
3 4
5 and what it means is drawing it out
five levels you can also So say you know
how how many when you want it to to
print you want it to print you know if
there's two stacked or three stacked
minimum of two or minimum of three
minimum of four you know it depends on
on what you want you can you know so you
can make some adjustments there and you
know the percentage volume or sorry the
imbalance trigger you know if you wanted
400% you put in 400 you wanted 300% you
wanted a th000% you can adjust it and
you know minimum volume say you know if
if you only want to
see stacked imbalances, you know, that
are above 200 lots, you can do that. You
could put in 200. So, you'd see, you
know, you'd only see this one. You
wouldn't see this wouldn't qualify. This
wouldn't
qualify. But anyway, you know, so
getting back to the stacked imbalances
and you have this stacked buying balance
and it fails. Okay. But within this
zone, within this five price
zone, you
have a selling imbalance. Basically, you
have an opposing imbalance. You know,
initially it was bullish. Now you got a
bearish one. What you do is you go with
the bear. You go with the second one in
the direction of the second one. It's
usually a quite powerful
signal cuz what you saw earlier, you
know, everything's changed in the
market. It went from a strong buying
market to a strong selling market. And
what happens? Boom. You're getting short
here now, you know, 91 91 and a half.
And and what does the market do? It just
it just falls over. you know, you're
talking 91, you know, and we're doing
you're trading 86 and trade all the way
down to 84, but you know, you could have
got at least five points out of that
move. You know, it doesn't happen that
often, but when it does, you know, watch
out. You know, this one's not opposing.
Okay, this is, you know, a buying
imbalance and another a stack buying and
balance followed by another stack buying
imbalance. But it's still within this,
you know, this zone is goes out five
levels that you can set it, you know,
say you want it to go 10 levels. You
know, I don't expect this stag buying
imbalance to hold all day. You know, it
for me it's a short-term thing. You
know, I'm looking for it to continue in
that direction. And if the market pulls
back within these five bars, I'm looking
for it to act as support. If it doesn't
hold, if the market just falls over,
then yeah, obviously it failed. But
again, I'm not looking for this staged
buying imbalance to be a level if we
come back to it three hours later for it
to hold. No, I'm just looking at it in
the short term because I know that when
you're trading, you
know, and now I'm speaking from
experience, you know, I used to work at
the biggest bank in the world. Well,
biggest bank in America. No, probably
not the biggest bank bank of America. I
think it's the biggest. It's it's one of
the biggest is JP Morgan. And I know
what it's like when you're trying to
work an order through the market. You're
trying to buy a lot. You're going to be
aggressive at certain levels. You want
need to get a lot on board. And if the
market's going to come back down to your
level, think you'll you'll often buy
more, you know. So, I can sort of read
that what's happening here is the guy
starts working his order in here trying
to buy, gets aggressive, market shoots
higher, [__] and he'd get more done. He
gets aggressive again to finish up his
order. He's done. He all he cares about
is his average price on this fill. His
average price is probably somewhere
around this uh 85, you know, quarter
area. And then the market goes higher.
You know, yeah, it did pull back and
then what these levels are holding. this
level held, this level kind of held.
But, you know, really what I'm more
interested in is when you have a buying
imbalance followed by a selling
imbalance. You know, it again, you know,
this is the 27th, so it's the day after
it's the Monday after Brexit. So, you're
getting a lot of strange things in the
market. And, you know, you don't usually
get two in a day. You usually get one if
that. And it's not something that
happens every day. But, you know, when
you see them happening within the five
price areas, you know, within the zone,
you know, pay attention to it. This
one's a little bit out of it. Um, you
got this selling imbalance. Again, this
one didn't work, you know, like if
you're getting short, you would have
been stopped out here. I would have
loved to see this buying imbalance
happened in here. This was a nice one.
It did it went up, but again, you know,
to me, I wouldn't qualify that one as as
as as a trade that I would have taken
with the uh overlapping imbalances.
Okay. not here. Okay. Yeah, you're
selling imbalance. All right. You're
selling off. Boom, boom, boom, boom. Big
sellers come in and it's holding as as
uh resistance. You can see it here. Then
you hit this area down here, right? And
then what happens? You changed. It went
from a supply driven market, a lot of
supply in the market to a demand driven
market. And you see sellers have now
become the buyer. I'll say become the
buyers, but what you saw earlier was a
lot of selling. And now you're seeing a
lot of buying in the opposite direction.
And what happens here? You know, you're
talking from this 88 level, trades up
to, you know, the 90s. Yeah, it came
back here, you know, and then sort of
went sideways, but you know, really the
move was here from here to here. This is
the price rejector giving you a sell,
you know, yet. So, basically had, you
know, a few, you know, this day is not
even over yet. This is uh one in the
afternoon here. I don't know if how many
there were this
day. Those these weren't overlapping.
It's too much time
passed. Okay. And then we're closed for
the day here. So that was again that was
the 27th. Let's see if there's anything
on the 28th. This is the Asian hours. Uh
not usually really interested in doing
much trading during Asian hours and the
S&Ps. I'd rather trade
Nikai. Uh what are we doing? Anything?
Anything? Nothing. This is the 28th so
far. Nothing. There's a selling
imbalance that
failed.
Uh buy and balance. Yeah, that worked.
You know, then you got another one
later, but you know, it's too far
apart. Okay, this one I don't know what
happened. It was something glitch in my
data there or something came out, but uh
okay. I mean, I don't know what happened
here. Uh as far as my data goes, there's
a gap
there. So, I'm not even sure if this
this one should be there, but
nevertheless, you know, it just it did
start to go. It did go down. um you know
a couple points you know but when I see
something like this I I think there was
a sort of a hiccup in the data coming
out from the exchange you know I see
this time we got all this 1433 I don't
know if somebody said something or you
know came out but to me that just looks
a bit uh a bit dodgy you know sometimes
you get bad data that's the problem with
uh you know trading on a retail level if
you're trading on a institutional level
you know you got Bloomberg and you got
uh basically the best one of the best
quote systems in the
world. Nothing. You know, that's just
one by itself. That's one by itself.
It's one by
itself. You know what you want to see is
when they're overlapping that zone. This
one just by itself. Okay.
Here we rally up. Boom. Sellers come in.
You're starting to thinking, hey, you
know, this is our swing high. You know,
you got a divergence there. And you got
the selling imbalance and you're
thinking, [__] I got to get short. And
you get short in here. But then you got
buy imbalance, you know, in the 1, two,
three, in the third bar from the selling
imbalance. You know, this is what I'm
talking about. You got to get in um you
know, when you see these things, again,
this is at 3:30 in the afternoon. It's a
little bit late, but sometimes you're
going to get these big moves going into
the cash close. It's the 29th this day,
so it's Tuesday. So, you know, you can
be getting in here somewhere, you know,
around the 66, 66 and a half level. And
look at that. It's just a nice move all
the way up until the close. you know,
it's it's a nice eightoint move straight
up basically. No pullback. You didn't
take any heat in this trade. Yeah. Yeah.
Maybe you took uh you know, two ticks of
heat, you know. I mean, you say you're
getting in in here. Yeah. You take one,
two, three, three ticks of heat, but it
looks like it turned around pretty
quick. So, you know, that's a beautiful
move. That's what you want to see in the
market. Uh so, let's go. Oh, this is the
30th. And like I said, you know,
sometimes these things, you know, they
you get days where you got a couple in a
row and days where you get none. This
one is a little bit outside of the
range. You know, you have this is in the
sixth bar here, so that's the seventh
bar. Uh that's just by itself. This one,
okay, this one, you got the buying
imbalance and you got the stack selling
imbalance. You know, this one didn't
work. It
it just, you know, it came back up in
here. Honestly, I would have been I'd be
looking to take take a loss in that at
trading here. I wouldn't be looking to
hold it in here. So, I mean, that was
the first one that that
failed, you know, and this the 30th. You
saw how many that were were winners.
Okay, here again. This one. Yeah, I
don't remember what happened at 10:30 at
this time. Uh there was something I
can't remember now. Last week was a it
seems like such a long time ago. But uh
you know this one you know again I
prefer to have opposing ones. You know
I'm not a big fan of getting um you know
buying a balance buying a balance
because sometimes you what you're going
to have is you're going to have a stop
that runs through especially if you're
using a shortterm shorter term chart.
You know this is a four range chart. If
I was using a 10 range chart you know I
probably you know all this volume that's
here would fill in and so you wouldn't
have a lot of these imbalances. Some of
these would be gone. I don't think you'd
have this stack and balance in here if
if I was using a slightly longer chart.
But, you know, we came up here and I've
got I got a couple negative things here
in the order flow, you know, telling me
to to bail
out. That one's by
itself. Okay. So, that was that was it
for that day. Now this is Friday the 1st
of
July. Again I'm looking for imbalances
that are occurring
within you know within the
zone. This one is just you know too far
out of it and that's it. So there was
nothing on
Friday. Okay. So you know thanks for
watching this video. If you want to
learn a little bit more about orderflow
trading you know come visit my website
www.orderflows.com
orderflows.com and you know you're sure
to pick something up. If you know you're
interested in my software, you know,
send me an email. There's a
contact contact uh form on my website
that you could just fill out and it'll
it'll get to me, you know, and you know,
it's you know, orderflow is great. It's
a great way to analyze the market. Now,
you know, I'm sure somebody will
probably watch this video and come out
with an indicator and try and sell it as
the imbalance algo indicator, but here
you can see it for free. You know, if
you have an any type of order flow
footprint chart, you can you can use it.
You can, you know, use what I taught you
there. Um, you don't need any special
programming or anything like that. As
long as it can read market imbalances,
then you know you should be able to take
advantage of
uh of overlapping imbalances when they
occur in the market. You know, again, I
I I don't use imbalances to act as a
support or resistance level other than
you know immediate term. I again I don't
look for it to market to move and start
trading over the next hour and two hours
and then come back to that level and
react to it. You know, again, I'm
looking at it in the short term. So,
again, you know, if you want to learn
more about Orderflow, uh, visit my
website,
ww.orderflows.com. So, thanks and see
you on the inside. Bye-bye.